we teamed up with a Seminole Hard Rock
Hotel & Casino in Hollywood Florida for
their amazing new expansion the stars
came out to play and smash a few guitars
to
[Music]
are you ready to smash the guitar
tonight I'm doing my old stomping ground
record I'm literally so excited the fact
that I get to stand next to Morgan
Freeman it smashed guitar it's I mean
thank you hard rock dreams come true the
1.5 billion dollar expansion project
includes the world's first guitar hotel
its 450 feet high and designed to look
like two back-to-back guitars and here's
the secret we learned about reality star
Tyler cameras I actually worked here on
the construction part of this when I was
like six months before the show I do a
construction as an intern it's like
learning learning learning and now I'm
actually here for this event which is
like a total 180 from what I was doing
[Music]
for you right now yeah I work in there
doing this yeah that's pretty cool the
star-studded party continues tonight
what are some of the opening festivities
that are going maroon 5 is obviously
kicking off Hard Rock Live in the
theater the theater holds 7,000 the
concert is sold out but you can't open a
Hard Rock Hotel without the signature
guitars smashed
[Music]